Thomas stanker there's a second partner
Thanks I don't think I can deliver on
all the promises that John made about my
talk so I'm gonna be talking about the
same topic basically and I'm gonna be
talking about a bunch of different works
but most what I'm talking about is
actually based on drug work with Vitali
Feldman who is here in the audience so
as you probably noticed John I submitted
iid abstracts but the good news is that
we did actually coordinate our talks and
I am going to talk about something
different so I'm gonna talk to you first
of all just give a very brief recap of
the setting that John talked about but
I'm going to talk to you about
distribution to pain and accuracy
counties I'm going to talk about really
focusing on the sort of accuracy
guarantees that we can get in this
adaptive setting and then I'm going to
talk about using weaker notions and
differential privacy and connecting
these ideas to information theory and
still retaining the generalization
properties okay so John did a great job
of covering motivation basically
adaptivity is a complex issue that seems
to be lurking in the background causing
a lot of problems and statistics and
machine learning in all kinds of
empirical sciences so John gave us a
model in which we can study this
formally so I'll just recap that model
so the two main actors are you have a
population that you're trying to study
which is a distribution and you have
someone who's interested in that and
they're basically asking some real
valued queries that wouldn't they have
some function they want to know what the
expectation of that function is on the
distribution and the way they compute
that because they don't actually know
the whole population is they sample in
iid samples from their population they
stick that into their favorite algorithm
and then they start asking a bunch of
queries and you know a good example of
this would be you know the analyst is
just asking give me a grade and give me
a grading because they're doing gradient
descent
and the thing that makes us adaptive is
that the queries are being specified one
by one you can each query can depend on
the the previous answers but in the non
adaptive setting that's easier you
specify the queries over once
okay so specified while the model is now
the question is how do you measure
accuracy and the definition of accuracy
that John spent most of his time talking
about is sum of an absolute accuracy
guarantee so the answer that is reported
by the the mechanism relative to the
true answer which is the expectation on
the population should be close just as
real numbers so the question is could be
hoped for better than that and you know
we could actually hope to get a better
answer if we take into account the
distribution so I'm going to talk about
is distribution dependent accuracy
guarantees so I could hope that these
answers are close in a way that depends
on the standard deviation of the value
so this is the accuracy guarantee that
you would get if you had T fresh samples
from the distribution and you can prove
this just by taking a you know Chernov a
a bernstein inequality or Sheamus you
have an equality to get the sort of
concentration mountain so this is the
main difference between what john was
talking about and what i'm going to be
talking about now so any any questions
before I move on to actually talking
about the results
okay so this is just the recap of the
result that that John gave so we have an
efficient algorithm that gives us a
bunch of answers to adaptive queries
with some accuracy guarantee that's sort
of a fourth root of K uh one important
difference between John of me is that I
use square root square root rather than
fourth root it's a it's a difference of
taste what I'm gonna be talking to you
about now is a guarantee which looks
very similar except now I'm gonna bring
in the variance of that query so I hope
you can sort of see that this result
dominates the previous one except for
some annoying log factors and basically
that's because the variance is a most
one so the goal is to get accuracy
guarantees that scale with the variance
but we still get some absolute error
beta but ignore that time so why might
this be interesting well I want to argue
to you that you actually in practice you
often do want to ask very low variance
queries and you know one example is if
you're tasting the accuracy of your
classifier sure if your classifier is
50% accurate then there's no difference
between these results but you've got
bigger problems than that there's a good
an accurate a classifier that's 99%
accurate then the variance is going to
be much lower so you're going to get
much better estimate of the accuracy
using these results
okay so the the previous work that John
was talking about the accuracy
guarantees scales with the worst case
sensitivity of the query so if you take
the pot largest possible value and the
smallest possible value could possibly
attain and it doesn't really matter what
probability though is attached to those
where as what I'm talking about the
accuracy guarantees with the standard
deviation and the sensitivity is
essentially irrelevant I I would argue
this is the natural scale of things if
you're doing normal statistics we I'm
worried about a adaptivity the standard
deviation is basically the scale that
you use to measure your accuracy and as
I mentioned if you're trying to measure
a binary query such as you is my
classifier making an error you're going
to get a pretty significant difference
if the true error is P then the accuracy
guarantee that scales with variance is
going to scale with root P and I should
also add that the extensions that John
talked about where you exploit having a
low dimensional you those also carry
over here and essentially the message
that I want to push to you with these
results is that if you're answering K
queries that are adaptively chosen what
we can do is we can affect you know the
obvious thing to do is collect T fresh
samples for each query that of course
would give you K times T samples in
total that you need what we're saying is
you can get away with square root K
times T samples so you're able to sort
of simulate having a lot more data than
you really have
okay so how would I go about proving
such a result so I'll just tell you what
the ingredients are so the first
ingredient is the connection between
stability or differential privacy and
generalization and that's exactly what
John was talking about and you know we
know that differential privacy gives us
these nice generalization guarantees and
the important thing is that it is able
to compose adaptively so when you run
multiple differentially private
algorithms even if you're running them
in an adaptive fashion it's still
differentially private the other
ingredient is that we add in the median
of means tricks this gets used in
various places but basically the idea is
that if you take the median of a bunch
of values that's going to be much much
more well-behaved than say an average in
some sense and of course we need to have
a differential private algorithm to
compute this
so what does the algorithm look like
schematically so we get a bunch of
queries and for each career we're going
to do the following so you take our
whole data set and you split it up into
a bunch of sub data sets of size T and
you evaluate the query on each of those
sub data sets and then you compute
naproxen median and that's your answer
so comparing that to the algorithm that
John was describing and the previous
helm you compute the query on the whole
day to see it and you just add some
noise so our algorithm it more
complicated but you know as a result we
get these improved accuracy guarantees
so what I mean by computing an
approximate median that's that's
something that I have told you is an
essential ingredient what do I mean by
that well I said you compute a bunch of
values and you know those values are
going to give you a distribution but
it's a discrete distribution so the CDF
of that distribution is going to look
like this blue line its approximating
some true distribution which is if you
had you know infinite data what we're
looking at is you know if I look at some
this between the 60th percentile and
40th percentile any pre image of that is
going to be what I call an approximate
median and the reason differential
privacy comes in here is that we use it
to say that the red line and blue line
which is the true CDF and the empirical
CDF on your data are close and nearly
have ingredient as I say it is having
good differentially private algorithms
so I'll give you so we have algorithms
that will find some pre image of these
percentiles
it's it's even better than that we just
assumed something about its first moment
and even even that is we can go even
weaker than that all we're assuming
about your query is that yes so the what
we're assuming about the query is that
basically you're interested in an
interval and your query falls into that
interval with probability at least you
want the same how low can we go I think
75 is but basically all we're saying is
that your query falls into some interval
with probability at least say 51% now if
you think about it if I get a whole
bunch of samples I'm gonna take the
median and with high probability the
median is gonna fall in that interval so
what I'm saying is that you could even
relax the variance you don't you could
use it use like a first moment or you
could use you know just whatever is like
the the interquartile range so we can
get away with extremely weak assumptions
okay great so I've given you a schematic
of how the algorithm works and sort of
the two ingredients how they fit in
together so I just want to explain to
you how you would actually compute a
approximate median and differentially
private manner and it's actually
extremely simple
I just explicitly write out the
distribution so I'm gonna output a value
a with probability proportional to sort
of how far its CDF differs from from the
desired value so even if the CDF is 1/2
this is going to be its maximum value
and if we actually plot this out you can
sort of think of it as here are your
data points on the real line and I have
my probability mass function sort of
peaking at the true median and sort of
decaying exponentially as I go further
away I'm just sampling from that
distribution so computing a
differentially private approximate
median is actually quite simple but it
will add that there are you can count
with algorithms that are a lot more
sophisticated than this well more
complicated and they get you to to the
log star dependence on the total range I
want to talk about those ok so any
questions about the algorithm
so the key win of doing this whole
splitting things up and taking a median
is that changing one of these inputs can
only sort of you only changing one of
these guys it can't really change the
CDF very much and therefore account move
the approximate median but if I were to
take a mean then I could change things a
lot more
so I also mentioned that their their
various extensions so we can extend this
to any real valued estimator I don't
need to be just asking for the
expectation of some sort of single
function of a single data point I could
try estimating the variance of the
distribution by taking two data points
any any estimator really the only
assumption that we're making here is
that it's real valued so things get a
little problematic if you look at things
that have more complex values but that's
pretty high generality another important
extension which John briefly mentioned
is the real reusable holdout so the idea
behind that is that it's very expensive
to answer K adaptive queries if you know
nothing about them but you can actually
get away with a lot better if you are
trying to just use it as a holdout sand
which is to say that you have a gas for
each answer and you're just trying to
verify whether that gas is correct
you can also get better results so you
get a logarithmic dependence on the
number of queries if you assume that the
the data domain is reasonably small
again as you as you asked after John's
talk we're starting to get this T to the
three-halves so and when you rearrange
that you're getting this cube root
rather than square root dependence which
it's unfortunate but we don't really
know how to avoid that
okay cool so the message that I hope
I've managed to communicate to you again
which I'll repeat is that we're able to
sort of simulate having K batches of T
fresh samples using sublinear and K
samples okay great so this is the
algorithm that I told you about it's
it's wonderful and beautiful but it's
kind of kind of complicated you know
you're really going to be doing this in
practice so you know the question that I
want to address in the remaining time
how much time do I have by the way ten
minutes okay great so the the question
all in address was the remaining time is
is there a simpler algorithm that we
could use and I will answer that
question in the affirmative so the the
previous algorithm that's just giving
you guarantees that are absolute doesn't
depend on the distribution is just to
compute the empirical answer and add
some Gaussian noise there's a previous
salesroom very nice and simple and the
question is you know could we could we
modify this algorithm and keep the same
schematic and still get guarantees that
scale with the with the variance of the
distribution
the answer is yes so what I want to talk
to you about is an algorithm that takes
the empirical answer and adds Gaussian
noise but now the Gaussian noise is
going to scale with the variance of the
of the query so this is the empirical
variance but it doesn't really matter
all right so previously you just have
sort of a 1 of a tee and no scaling with
the variance we makes you show that this
particular algorithm attains this
accuracy guarantee so you're probably
thinking what is this has got some
expectation of a maximum of some some
ratio so let me try unpacking that for
you so this is the the error that we're
getting from the jQuery and this is the
sort of desired bound this is the
variance scale by one of a t plus some
sort of base factor and we're saying
that the expectation of this is small
which particular means that with decent
probability it's small so I could take
for example a markov inequality bound
and sort of show that with reasonable
probability the error the maximum error
scales with the the variance so maybe
it's a comparison point this is the the
result that we had for the complicated
mechanism with the approximate median
and if you were to just take Markos
inequality you get a similar result but
the beta would be not as good so the
dependence on the these beta parameters
is worse but otherwise is basically the
same result
okay so I've told you this algorithm
that sort of seems kind of natural you
take your empirical outs you had some
noise but you make that noise scale to
the the accuracy guarantee that you want
but how do we actually analyze this so
previously we've used differential
privacy to do to do the analysis but it
turns out this algorithm just doesn't
satisfy differential privacy at the
level that we need to prove the desired
goal so what we're just going to use is
a relaxation of differential privacy so
in this that's weaker than differential
privacy we call this average leave one
out kale stability so what does that
mean so if you look at the distribution
of the algorithm on some input data set
s and then we're going to compare it
with KL divergence to the the same
algorithm but where you remove one of
the data points remove a data point at
random so we're over the N data points
and we're going to say this is smaller
than Epsilon this is a relaxation of
differential privacy in two different
ways so the first is that KL divergence
is weaker than the similarity guarantee
that you get in differential privacy no
formally that's not quite true but
morally that is and this weakness is why
we only get a bound that has the
expectation we don't really get these
strong high probability bounds that we
were getting before the other relaxation
is that we're now averaging over the
endpoints of the data set previously we
said pick pick the worst data point and
replace that and so what we're now
allowing is that song you know if you
think of this in terms of privacy some
of the people might actually have their
privacy seriously harmed but on average
people's privacy is not very harmed so
you know in comparison to maybe I just
pick a random person in the room and
completely violate their privacy you
know this would on average be okay but
would certainly not satisfy differential
privacy
so first things first
adding the scale Gaussian noise that I
told you about does satisfy this
definition that's a kind of messy
calculation but it's it's true and sort
of the really magical property that got
me excited about this
is that this definition composes
adaptively what do I mean by that I mean
that if you answer K a queer K queries
each adaptively chosen then the ape
Salons just add up and that's really the
whole reason why we use differential
privacy here so I think a lot of people
wonder why differential privacy is being
used in this regime where privacy is not
a concern and the reason is this ability
to compose adaptively and this
definition is able to satisfy that and
of course the the final property of the
three that we want is that this
guarantees summarization properties okay
so here's the definition and now I want
to tell you how you get some
generalization properties from this and
the the key lemma here is that if you
have this average stability and you take
a random iid data say it then the mutual
information between the data say it and
the output of the algorithm is down to
by epsilon in and this Baumer mutual
information has been identified as a
really good way of proving
generalization results in particular
root zones Oh showed basically that you
know once you have this bound on mutual
information you're able to get bounced
so bounds on generalization so you might
be wondering what this complex
inequality here is the second one of my
favorite inequalities and basically what
it's saying is that okay if the mutual
information is small
and then I can bound I can relate the
expectation of some arbitrary function
of the data set in the output to the
moment generating function of that if I
have an independent data set so if we
pop up the the theory though we're
trying to prove let's look at this
quantity here this is my F of s and Q
this this quantity if the queries are
independent of the data and I just use
the empirical answers this would be very
well-behaved and what this so that's
telling me that this this term over here
is bounded stability is telling me that
the mutual information is bounded and
that's giving me a bound that is
precisely this thing here that's so if
the mutual information between these two
things is zero that means they're
independent that means the the queries
that have been asked of your data are
independent of the data set or just in
the classical non-adaptive world and
this is just a quantitative version of
that statement if you have bounds on the
mutual information you're also going to
get some relationship to the moment
depth of world yes so we also need to
show that the empirical variance is
close to the true variance so that's a
separate lemma that goes into the proof
of this
I know the assumption that I'm making is
that these are bounded between 0 & 1
I realize knock that in previously I
just said there were there were kind of
arbitrary real valued things but I'm I'm
sneaking that boundedness assumption
back in there's only into the second
order term this was 1 over T yes 1 is 4
is it of the range so it's kind of just
move it to the second order very
okay so the the key points is that
adding scaled noises in the still give
us adaptive generalization guarantees so
that's kind of you know really nice I
think it's nice so we have a simple
algorithm that's still giving us
guarantees that scale with the the data
distribution and I also really like the
fact that we have this relaxed notion of
differential privacy this average
stability and we're able to show there's
a useful way of ensuring generalization
and again the key property that sort of
makes this thing interesting is that it
composes adaptively and the analysis
through mutual information I think is a
very clean observation due to Rousseau
and so this is a very very sort of
general way of understanding overfitting
and generalization any questions at this
stage okay great
[Applause]
that's a good question I don't I I don't
know ever connections per that way
that's interesting question I don't know
[Applause]